grosse nouveauté en termes de sécurité
sur les iPhone Apple vient de lancer une
détection d'accident et également des
appels d'urgence par satellite grâce à
un nouveau gyroscope un nouvel accès
romain vous avez la détection des
accidents dès lors que vous avez un
accident on va vous dire ok vous allez
bien alors soit vous dites je vais bien
soit vous n'allez pas bien et à ce
moment-là les secours vont être appelés
ils vont avoir votre position GPS et
vont venir arriver directement jusqu'à
vous entre nouveautés et pas des
moindres c'est les secours par satellite
lorsque vous êtes paumé en haut d'une
montagne ou dans la pompe à je ne sais
pas où vous prenez votre smartphone et
votre iPhone va vous guider pour venir
pointer face au satellite le plus proche
vous allez ensuite pouvoir communiquer
par message grâce à un centre de secours
les secours finiront pas arriver pour
venir vous récupérer alors cette
fonctionnalité est disponible uniquement
aux États-Unis et au Canada mais on
pourrait imaginer qu'elle arriverait un
peu partout dans le monde très
prochainement est-ce que ça vous
rassurer d'avoir ces solutions de
sécurité dites-moi ça en commentaire et
puis poursuivre toute la queue tech je
vous invite à dire vous abonner